paris place du trocadéro
ces manifestants sont les témoins de
l'un des plus vieux conflits de
l'histoire moderne en france ils sont
considérés comme marocain mais au se
revendique sahraouis leur drapeau celui
du sahara occidental est interdite sur
leur terre une terre occupée par le
maroc depuis 1975
oui père qu'il saignait puis détruites
des centaines de sahraouis sont arrêtés
torturés ensuite tué ainsi que des
milliers de disparus ce bilan
malheureusement salon dit de jour en
jour et la france ainsi que ses citoyens
c'est radio et ses chaînes télévision
reste silencieux à ce massacre la
plupart ici sont réfugiées ou enfants de
réfugiés comme aminetou 21 ans né en
france son grand père a été assassiné
sous les yeux de son père au tout début
du conflit elle à la cause sahraouie
chevillée au corps c'est injuste que que
c'est pape n'a pas le droit à ça à son
indépendance parce qu'on est quand même
en 2010 et que c'est quand même injuste
de devoir encore à payer encore
colonisées par l'état marocain
le sahara occidental un conflit vieux de
35 ans
en 1975 cette ancienne colonie espagnole
annexée par le maroc les sahraouis s'y
opposent la guerre éclate
les marocains se protège ton en érigeant
un mur de sable blond de 2700 km le
conflit prend fin en 1991 date à
laquelle d'onu propose un référendum
d'autodétermination de la région une
consultation populaire qui n'a à ce jour
jamais eu lieu
quand oubliés des médias le sahara
occidental capte de nouveau l'attention
en novembre dernier les forces de
l'ordre marocaines donnent l'assaut dans
un camp de sahraouis à laâyoune
chef-lieu de la région bilan officiel
marocain douze morts dont dix policiers
et 163 arrestations
retour à paris
les récents événements de laâyoune ont
attisé les revendications des sahraouis
exilé
à mesure que le conflit s'enlise là bas
ici la diaspora resserrent les rangs
ça oui si on est vraiment soudée on est
lié quand on a une manifestation les
tous présents on essaie de se donner
deux à trois fois par mois d'organiser
des fêtes ça oui il soin
de ne pas oublier qui on est malgré
qu'on a grandi en france d'où l'on vient
fin de manif soudain au milieu des
drapeaux sahraouis surgit un drapeau
marocain
immédiatement considéré comme une
provocation les esprits s'échauffent
l'altercation sera brève elle ne fera
pas de blessé
[Musique]
lendemain de mobilisation rendez vous
avec aminé tout et deux activistes
historique sahraouis brahim ballard et
brahim sabbar ou trois rendre visite un
soutien français de poids l'avocate
france veille elle suit au maroc la
plupart des procès de militants
sahraouis
deux femmes de leur famille de la
situation serait pettitte et d'antiques
mot celle de soi de 76,2 début de
l'invasion il y a les arrestations
arbitraires c'est des vagues c'est pas
une adhésion des vagues d'arrestations
arbitraires et ce qui est terrible c'est
qu'on n'a pas réussi on n'arrive pas à
avoir des informations fiables puisque
tous les observateurs sont empêchés d'y
aller il ya les députés ont pas été
autorisés à entrer les journalistes
n'ont pas été autorisés à rentrer mais
combien y aura-t-il de nouveau de
disparitions forcées dont on parlera
dans dix ans dix ans on est désolé on
savait pas si on peut savoir aujourd'hui
les disparitions forcées nos deux brahim
peuvent en parler de 1981 1991 ils ont
passé dix ans ensemble dans le bagne
secret de kate mc goudelin au sud du
maroc by ballard à 56 ans il a obtenu
l'asile en france il ya 14 ans
on a passé des allées et notre quotidien
c'est l'hymne il ya sion la torture
physique et morale
la sous-alimentation il y à 28 personnes
qui sont morts at 10 et le nombre salle
à s'allonger à calatayud jusqu'à
quarante trois hommes et deux femmes
brahim sabbar 51 ans vit toujours au
sahara mais depuis les récents
événements son engagement lui interdit
de rentrer chez lui
gvt et
les jeunes les plus les mineurs de dix
ans et 2 ans et intérêts devant moi et
même
il ne faut pas céder à la
posséder
n'est pas dingue comme ça là maintenant
le peuple sahraoui n'a pas le choix
c'est le retour langage des armes et
c'est la seule solution qui peut
débloquer cette situation parce que
maintenant la situation est bloquée
totalement c'est vrai que le peuple
sahraoui a assez souffert comme ça
et et c'est vrai qu'en ce moment c'est
la seule chose qu'ils demandent c'est la
guerre comme ils disent eux ils disent
que en fait la guerre hyper hyper de
rien parce que ils ont déjà assez perdu
leurs proches ils ont déjà assez été
torturé et leurs terres donc ils peur de
rien
une guerre qui n'arrangerait personne
dans la région ni le maroc ni le voisin
algérien pourtant le dialogue semble
être dans l'impasse
pour comprendre ce qui anime la
communauté sahraouie direction les
mureaux en grande banlieue de paris
c'est ici que vit à miner tout comme bon
nombre des 20000 sahraouis de france au
programme cet après midi fête
traditionnelle
[Musique]
rien d'incongru alors adressé la tente
sur le carrelage de la salle des fêtes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la culture sahraouie c'est une langue le
hassani un folklore d'un mode de vie
différent des us et coutumes marocain
on reproche aux marocains
c'est pas qu'on n'aime pas la couleur
culture au contraire alors que tu rossi
elle est belle mais notre culture à nous
aussi est belle et on a envie de la
conserver
[Musique]
élément fédérateur par excellence le
drapeau porte l'histoire et les espoirs
de la lutte
[Musique]
on connaît encore un territoire occupé
le conte est décevant car
elles sont
le sens des gens qui sont qu'ils ont
bâti elles font pas dix pour le
territoire salle le blanc c'est la paix
les comités de faire plusieurs couleurs
à notre indépendance mais tous les pays
où normale aux travaux notre sens le
versement aux et le noir voilà ça c'est
un héritage comme il faut
on prend bien soin de lui
[Musique]
pour aminé tout la journée se terminera
en dansant
[Musique]
le
à
2 vingt-cinq ans après le début du
conflit des sahraouis de paris comptent
bien quel qu'en soit le prix faire
goûter à leurs enfants la paix du désert
[Musique]